[Musique]
monsieur le premier ministre
bonjour je souligne que vous êtes dans
votre résidence parce que par prudence
comme vous avez côtoyé quelqu'un qui a
eu la lacc au vide
vous prenez encore quelques jours n'est
ce pas oui effectivement j'ai rencontré
monsieur hutu lundi dernier donc jusqu'à
lundi prochain
ça va faire deux semaines donc c'était
un mode préventif mais pour l'instant
bon un j'ai eu un test négatif et 2g
aucun symptôme donc pour l'instant tout
va bien
bon c'est une bonne nouvelle hier vous
avez sûrement comme comme les canadiens
écouter le premier ministre hugo qui
avait demandé de faire une allocation
devant les canadiens en heure de grande
écoute et le message essentiellement
c'est à dire la deuxième vague pourrait
être pire
êtes vous d'accord avec cette analyse là
ce que c'est est ce que vous êtes au
même point que lui là dessus bah écoutez
d'abord pour l'instant ça s'annonce pas
pour être pire lors qu'un tronc garde
les hospitalisations puis les 17 la
préparation qu'on a entre autres dans
nos ch et celle des mois je pense pas
que ça s'annonce pour être pire mais on
sait pas ce qui va se passer dans un
mois dans deux mois donc le mieux vaut
prévenir et justement vous voulez
prévenir puis on a par un peu plus tard
de la clarté du message du gouvernement
mais vous voulez prévenir mais à ce que
les québécois sont encore à l écoute ou
d'après vous il ya une lassitude
vraiment qui s'est installée c'est votre
plus grand obstacle
oui effectivement là on voit qu'après
six mois et demi les québécois qu'il ya
certains québécois qui sont tannés
bon il reste encore quelques sceptiques
aussi qui croient que c'est pas vrai le
virus pour ça qu'on a mis de la
publicité avec décors réels mais
effectivement le défi cdd au jambon
d'abord le problème c'est dans les
maisons selon la santé publique c'est
pas dans les bars
c'est pas dans les restaurants c'est pas
dans les rassemblements extérieur c'est
vraiment dans les maisons que ce fait le
maximum de la transmission
donc le message au delà des couleurs
puis des chiffres c'est dire aux gens
ben dans les maisons autant que possible
recevait pas d'invités si vous en savez
ben receveuse un peu pour pas longtemps
idéalement pas plus que 10 minutes puis
idéalement avec un masque et puis deux
mètres de distance
c'est là que ça se passait dans les
maisons bon mais alors parlons-en tout
de suite là puis on va régler ça
le message a été confus la thur c'était
6 après ça c'était 4 ce qui a tué depuis
parfois deux dj par quatre j'imagine que
vous regardiez saviez variole en train
de s'entraîner demain et le monde plus
qu'autre chose là c'est parce que il ya
deux concepts ya le concept de la bulle
d'une famille donc s'il ya deux familles
ça peut être plus que six
mais idéalement même quand il ya deux
familles idéalement d'assez maximum 6
même si c'est seulement de famille qui
idéalement et des allemands ce qui est
pas d'invités qui viennent des autres
familles bon je comprenne un ami un
message là qui dépendent des zones dont
il ya des ondes ces 10 des 11 6
c'est effectivement peut-être compliqué
mais le message pourtant il est très
simple la recette là il n'ya pas un
grand miracle qui va se produire
fauqué moins de contact actuellement le
problème c'est dans une maison donc
idéalement rester à votre famille combat
de membres de l'autre famille ou d'amis
qui viennent nous visiter
quand les
des codes de couleurs ça pouvait être
attrayant effectivement sur une idée
théorique intéressante mais là qu'on
arrive aux oranje ont dit ouais mais
l'on ne sera pas aussi sévère qu'on
l'avait dit on fermera pas les salles à
manger par exemple on a juste allemand
quand on sait pu finalement ben en même
temps faute et compte la réalité on
pourrait bien être infirmée tous les
bars tous les restaurants sauf que c'est
pas là qu'est le problème problème c'est
dans les maisons donc faut s'ajuster
donc il faut effectivement avoir une
certaine flexibilité donc hauts de
l'aude nombre d'éclosions que dans
chaque région il ya aussi la cause de
ces éclosions qui à cause baissé dans
les maisons fait que faut pas non plus
attachés à dire bon il faudrait réduire
encore plus le nombre dans les bars dans
les restaurants ce pôle a pour l'instant
qu'un problème mais met donc si on veut
fermer cette parenthèse là pour la
clarification du message avez vous
envoyé un mot d'ordre en dix ans essayez
d'être de moins penser tout comme la
sphère des la police puis des résidences
privées la mer ou d'eau qui disséminent
en deux heures après on dit non non non
le lendemain est ce que vous avez comme
siffler la fin de la récréation dia on
peut tuer est clair qu'il faut penser
tout d'abord je ne rencontre à chaque
jour de même si je suis isolée ça pas
changer grand chose dans ma villa au
lieu de les rencontrer en personne je
les rencontre pas vidéoconférence
donc ce qu'on essaye de faire c'est
effectivement le d'être plus clair dans
le message
mais il faut comprendre que c'est pas
toujours simple entre autres la partie
légale de 10 rebonds s'ébaudit que les
personnes peuvent pas être plus que six
dans les maisons comment on fait pour
donner des contraventions
on sait qu'on policier peut pas forcer
une personne à ouvrir la porte mais il
peut donner quand même des infractions
cypress mandat donc c'est pas simple
puis on a des gens comme le docteur ou
d'autres qui sont pas des juristes puis
qui peut-être doivent ajuster les
messages qui aussi les libertés civiles
il ya 7 et qu'il est blanc maintenant
car effectivement écoutez là on a un
gros problème dans les maisons mais on
n'est pas pour commencer à voir la
police qui rentrent librement dans
toutes les maisons donc c'est un
équilibre qui est fragile pour ça que
j'ai besoin de la collaboration des
québécois c'est sérieux parce que ma
plus grande crainte c'est qu'on voit les
hospitalisations augmenté l'on est à
centre presse vitalisation ya un mois on
est rendu à plus de 180 dont segmente
lentement mais sûrement
puis là ça va nous amener s'arrête pas
d'augmenter à retarder déchirure gilles
qui peuvent être importantes qui sont
attendus par des patients donc moi je
dis aux québécois la incluant les jeunes
faites attention puis pendant quelques
semaines limitez vos contacts surtout
dans les maisons parce que vous touchez
quelque chose de fort important cette
semaine
mon collègue david gêne-t-il et citait
un rapport de votre gouvernement d'une
souris né serait la santé qui disait on
estime que 5000 québécois qui n'ont pas
été diagnostiquées de cancer qui
auraient dû l'être
on fait moins un diagnostic donc c'est
dangereux et une deuxième vague et là je
cite les mots de la sominice serait
dramatique pour le traitement du cancer
faut pas perdre de vue ce avez vous un
plat pour rattraper le retard
bon d'abord là donc faut être prudent
avec ce qui s'est passé depuis six mois
pour les personnes qui ont le cancer
d'abord il n'ya aucune chirurgies
urgentes où aucun traitement urgent ou
aucun test urgents qui étaient retardées
par quand il ya des québécois au
printemps dernier qui avait peur d'aller
à l'hôpital donc des québécois qui sont
pas allés demander pour un test où
allait subir des tests puis moi j'ai
d'un clair là on est capable de faire
tout les tests toutes les interventions
pour les personnes qui pensent qu'ils
ont le cancer ou qui ont le cancer donc
faut pas que les gens aient peur d'aller
à l'hôpital quand même un message
c'est qu'actuellement on est capable de
le faire mais là si on augmente mais
vous dites on est capable de faire votre
sous ministre dit une deuxième vague
aura un effet dramatique non pas sur les
patients atteints de cancers en
traitement vous avez raison les gens
sont traités
s'il continue à être traitée de façon
prioritaire mais plutôt sur les patients
non diagnostiquées puisque elle
entraînerait à nouveau une perturbation
est aussi une question de ressources la
wii mais je veux être clair ni par la
vague du printemps ni actuellement on
refuse des tests à des gens qui pensent
qu'ils ont le cancer donc ce sont plutôt
les personnes au printemps qui avait
peur d'aller à l'hôpital
mais tous ces tests le sont disponibles
par contre ce qu'on dit c'est faisons
attention si nombre d'hospitalisations
continue d'augmenter
ça pourrait mettre en péril ses services
comme actuellement tous les services de
diagnostic sont offerts la grosse
crainte que vous devez avoir qu'on ne
touche voyant ce qui est arrivé le drame
dans les milieux de vie pour personnes
âgées
c'est que ça entre à nouveau encore une
fois cette semaine entre gandhi depuis
début des fois entre les intentions et
la réalité il ya ces deux mondes le
président d'acs et des maisons pour
personnes âgées qui dit c'était
impossible de ne pas qu a pas de
mobilité moi je fais appel à 30% encore
de personnels qui viennent des agences
l'on parle de 6 h et celle des privés
non conventionnés et non pas publics il
vit encore un roulement de personnel
qu'est ce que vous allez faire pour
empêcher ça d'abord soyons là on a
embauché puis formé plus de 7000 préposé
donc de ce côté là c'est pas mal ce
contrôle par kung fu c'est la vérité il
ya beaucoup de postes d'infirmières et
d'infirmières auxiliaires sont pas
comblés donc ça peut arriver à
l'occasion que des chs ld soit obligé
de faire circuler certaines infirmières
entre les chs ld plutôt que de pas voir
personne pour servir mes clients donc on
n'est pas dans une situation qui est
idéal mais lorsqu'on a demandé au pdg
des six c'est à chaque fois que ça
arrive
pouvez-vous nous aviser faut vraiment
que ça soit exceptionnel puis seulement
parce qu'il nous manque d'infirmières
je reviens le gros par beck lyon 15
maisons rudy on a des employés qui
travaillent dans plusieurs
établissements pour arrondir leurs fins
de mois
souvent ils vont même travaillé en
hôtellerie et en restauration donc lui
la porte tournante existe encore dans
son monde à l'huile le la directive
qu'on a envoyé parce que le lieu des
vacances du personnel jusqu'au 30
septembre
c'est qu'à partir du 30 septembre ça
n'arrive plus donc il faut effectivement
qui est un ajustement on va essayer de
les aider à leur fournir du personnel
c'est pas évident parce que quand je
vous disais oui on a réglé pas mal le
problème des préposés aux bénéficiaires
mais on a encore un manque d'infirmières
et d'infirmières auxiliaires
mais l'objectif c'est que ça soit
strictement défendu qui que ce soit
seulement exceptionnel quand on n'est
pas capable de trouver d'employés avez
vous pu lire je sais pas vous avez eu
l'occasion hier de lire les deux
rapports sur elle et sur scène dorothée
sur la situation dramatique lieu là on
parle de roulement de personnel on parle
qui avait pas de patrons
puis quand il y avait des patrons il
n'était pas imputable personne d'un put
abl car premier ministre canadien dit à
la population ce serait bien qu'il ya
des normes nationales plus sévères pour
les milieux de vie des personnes âgées
on peut pas être content des normes plus
sévères monsieur la boue pas écouté
d'abord moi j'étais très choquée et
déçue du message de monsieur trudeau ou
hier soir parce que amenons les choses
en perspective quand on a pris le
pouvoir il ya un an et demi il nous
manquait dix mille personnes dans les ch
à celle des durant la pandémie
il ya un autre dix mille employés qui
sont santé donc il nous manquait plus de
20000 employés
on a fait appel aux québécois puis à 21
milles québécois qui sont venus
travailler avec je contribue il en a
formé 7000 employés dans monsieur
trudeau nous dit pendant quelques mois
on a envoyé 1000 soldats actuellement il
ya 450 personnes la croix rouge
il faut remettre sa perspective le il
nous manque et 20000 employés
monsieur trudeau n'a envoyé 1000 puis là
monsieur trudeau veut se mêler des soins
de longue durée
la vérité c'est que on doit bauchet plus
de personnes et pour abu chez des
personnes ça prend du financement
récurrent mais ce trou d'où nous a donné
de l'argent cette année mais comment on
paye ses 7000 ou ses 10000 personnes là
de plus l'année prochaine
rappelons que le gouvernement fédéral
finançait 50 % des dépenses de santé
actuellement c'est rendu seulement 22%
donc plutôt être par l'énorme pitt
s'impliquent épuisé que l'huile
connaisseurs les chs ld qui fasse sa
part les gens envoient près de la moitié
de leurs impôts à ottawa
ça serait normal que tu avoir contribué
plus que 22% on leur demande de façon
très raisonnable toutes les provinces de
contribuer à 35 % des dépenses de santé
ce qui serait très bien ce qu'ils
seraient 70 milliards de dollars
effectivement qui viendraient mais ce
les gens les gens qui vous écoutent
doivent vérifier oui on vous appuyez
j'imagine les gens applaudissent mazza
oui il faut qu'il ya des fonds car il du
fédéral pour mieux s'occuper des vieux
mais ma question c'est dire sur les
chiens de compétences je veux bien pis
et c'est correct la grande tradition
québec nos chaussées non chose mais les
gens les québécois monsieur legault
s'attendent ou sinon à ce qu'il ya des
normes plus sévères dans ses résidences
là c'est ça mon point on peut pas être
content des normes plus sévères pour les
vieux ouais on est capable de le faire
au québec le pit déjà avec les
corrections qu'on a ajouté qu'on a fait
c'est à dire d'ajouter 7000 personnes
bientôt il va en avoir un autre 3000
donc dix mille personnes de plus dans
les ch celle d'e.on en train de se
donner des normes mais en même temps ces
buttes par les normes mais il faut
embaucher du personnel pour avoir du
personnel ça prend des fonds récurrents
puis vous le savez à cause des impacts
du vieillissement des nouvelles
technologies les coûts de la santé
augmente de 6% par année
puis les revenus augmentent de 3% donc
on a besoin d'une plus grande
contribution du fédéral
je pense pas qu'on a besoin de monsieur
trudeau pour nous disent qu'ils à faire
dans les ch de celle des si vous invite
à parce que j'imagine votre négociation
le kilo ce qui va s'accélérer
vous allez aller à la table puis
négocier quand même là même si lui
continue à répéter qu'il veut des normes
nationales plus sévère écoutez la
semaine dernière on a fait un point de
presse
puis on avait une position unanime les
13 premiers ministres des provinces et
des territoires
on demande d'augmenter les transferts de
28 milliards donc y faire passer de 20
2% des dépenses totales à 35 % des
dépenses totales que ça se fasse sans
condition donc tous les premiers
ministres demandent ça monsieur trudeau
puis depuis cette semaine c'est moi qui
le président du conseil de la fédération
donc on demande une rencontre monsieur
trudeau en demandent une date pour aller
régler ce problème là qu'est le problème
le plus urgent qui est empiré avec la
pandémie actuellement on a déjà vu je
vais vous laisser aller monsieur legault
à prendre déjà vu des front commun
s'effriter quand il ya des provinces qui
voit le chèque qui disent bien dans le
fond on va accepter ça s'est vu à
plusieurs reprises il n'y a pas tant
d'années nombre non plus est-ce que vous
avez est ce que vous croyez que votre
front commun il est solide
bah écoutez je ne raconte cet après midi
de deux heures acté premier unissent des
autres provinces
c'est la demande qu'on a fait d'avoir
une augmentation de transfert sans
condition je pense qu'il ya une question
aussi de saine gestion
je le dis souvent quand les deux patrons
lieu puis de patron donc je pense les
provinces préfère gérer le réseau de la
santé c'est dans leurs compétences
moi je pense que
et j'espère qu'ils seront communs là va
durer vous m'aviez dit lors de la
dernière entrevue il va avoir des vrais
patrons dans les sachets celle des
suisses saas et 15 quand il va voir des
vrais patrons imputable c'est déjà le
col puis il faut comparer actuellement
on a à peu près 200 quelques personnes
qui sont infectées dans les sièges celle
des on en avait 6000 à 8000 au printemps
donc ses limites et ses des exceptions
les gens portent les masques porte
l'équipement de protection individuelle
puis il ya un patron qui s'assure
d'avoir l'inventaire nécessaire
d'équipements de protection personnelle
puis s'assurer que les employés portent
cet équipement donc ces faibles cela
gros merci de nous avoir accordé cette
entrevue on va se reparler je voulais
vous parler d'économie mais on va je
pense que les personnes âgées ça valait
la peine qu'on s'attarde là dessus c'est
leur prochain combat puis on veut pas
l'échapper cette fois-ci merci beaucoup
monsieur merci de se revoir et à bientôt